hey everybody welcome to another stream
super excited to be here playing league
of legends answering your questions ooh
I need to pick who my champion is I'm
going with Heimerdinger mid I have my
co-host reishi from rishi cut TV Rishi
how you doing hey good morning ever tell
you i am good I am so we had our first
stream earlier this week and had a
massive headache at the end of it I
trying to play a new champion that I
wasn't really familiar with an answer
questions the same time took an
unexpected toll on my on my brain so so
today I'm playing heimerdinger mid a
champion I'm much more comfortable with
and I'm playing with friend of the
channel Jason jrez fonseka who's would
be doing a rama stop and we'll see how
we do usually we have some pretty good
games together so we'll see but excited
let's get into the questions what do we
have hey super awesome well I'm not
seeing you on switch but i'm going to
quickly check here so i really want to
make sure i can see okay first question
is from colleen brown she says i have
conceptualized an e-commerce search
engine ask that i'm sure would
revolutionize the online shopping sphere
so what she wants to know from you is
how do i take steps in order to launch
and develop this idea for this
e-commerce search engine app okay so
just trying to market the idea i guess
she just has a good idea and she wants
to launch kind of like what should you
know where should she start what should
she do first is it the marketing side or
is it the text i like she should develop
it or she has she's developed it and she
wants to sell it she's specifically just
saying how do i take steps in order to
launch and develop this idea so it looks
like it might be a little bit of both ok
ok cool I liked it what are you I know I
uh well I think
the first thing would be I would want to
get some context on if this is an
industry that she's completely new to if
she is new to it and has no former
background I would say first thing
surround yourself with someone who is
really familiar with this industry Evan
I don't know I'm sure you have some
experience specifically with this
e-commerce search engine app but i would
start there getting getting some
feedback from people who have already
done what she's done and then and then
starting to think about how can she
differentiate what she's doing because I
I would assume it even though it sounds
like it's a revolutionary idea that she
has maybe someone else out there has
done something similar how would she
differentiate herself so that she can
stand out I like it what was her name
again calling brown coleen coleen a
couple things here for me first if you
haven't developed that you need to get a
developer on board and and and not just
like a contract developer you need a
unit business partner you need someone
who is committed to this you look at the
number of successful tech companies who
don't have someone in charge of tech
it's it doesn't really happen right like
you need to have somebody on board on
your team who gets attack who can see
your vision loves it and can you know do
their part to make it a success so
that's the first part I think I think
lots of people have these ideas for
starting an app or starting you know a
new website but they don't they can't
develop it and you can keep spending
money on developers I know the
developers and other developers but you
want to have somebody who is just as
committed as you and so I'd be looking
at how can I find a partner who I can
really connect with who shares my same
values who understands a mission that
we're on and can dedicate their time to
making some fun amazing happen
in terms of getting it out and marketing
the great thing about this kind of app
if it you know if it's good right that's
kind of the first thing you got to make
sure that this thing actually works and
you know why am I going to leave Google
to go to your appt right right Google is
pretty mobile friendly so are the other
search engines so what's so great about
yours like just being the same as google
is enough it's got to be massively
better to change people's habits but the
good thing is if it is that good this is
a search engine this is something that
people use multiple times a day right
it's not something that like buying a
car they might only do once every three
to five to seven years so if you have
something really really good people will
come back and then they'll tell their
friends and they use it over and over
and over again and they'll pick up their
phone and show the people there with
like look at how great this search
engine is and so that's great that that
the you have used and virality built
into the actual app itself but it has to
be good enough that's the caveat right
like you have to give me something that
I would want to talk about and so those
two things I think would be of critical
importance for you to launch this thing
finding a partner who you can connect
with who shares the same values who can
build this thing for you and be part of
your team not just a contract developer
and then making a product that people
actually care actually use and want to
share and tell their friends about
Colleen it's a good start yay I'm liking
it but Colleen got my full focus there
because I'm not in game you can see my
screen there I wish you I I can and I
that's why I was wondering if it was
delayed cuz right now i'm not seeing a
game i'm just being like a layout yeah
we're waiting even started no no we're
on time I'm heimerdinger I'm that guy
with the big glasses at the bottom and
enjoy Rises ram is he's the guy next to
me on the left with the turtle with the
big thorns coming out of him so cool I'm
a danger decent team here will sleep in
your cup Evan you gotta tell me oh well
I have a glass you know a glass I guess
it's like a cup I
glass of a vitaminwater vitamix Nina
Nina gives me vitamins that I have to
drink you keep me healthy and then when
I'm done that I have a humongous
smoothie danina made I've got a gigantic
bottle of water and I've got a special
delivery caramel macchiato from junior
eyes so I'm gonna be hydrated a lot
today what's in your cup roll your
forgot to ask you this usually are how
we start I know this is an early morning
so getting it together as the caffeine
is going down actually Jay rises on the
money I'm having my caramel caramel I
think it's it I don't know what the
masyado just a caramel latte from panera
so he's gonna go update his twitter bio
now say i am on the money he would if he
wasn't i aim with me tell us really
quickly really busy because i know a lot
of people are who are watching regularly
are going to want to know you were
mentioning mean and maybe some vitamin
water how is your stomach can you just
like if you all saw the video on Sunday
it was awesome you got to check it out
well it was an awesome news because it
was like Evan telling us at a stomach
was hurting but tell us how you're doing
the stomach is getting better uh it's
getting better it's getting better i
think by next week i'll be able to get
back into my my stepping routine you
should do in like thirty thousand steps
a day and i'm now at like six thousand
or something it's it's killing me i want
to be active I've stopped my workout it
so hopefully next week we'll be back I
got to go to New York next week to for a
quick trip and so gotta gotta get better
for them but getting better thank you
for asking okay well good we're we're
hoping you'd get better soon all right
you want the next question are you ready
yeah I'm ready hit me okay next question
comes from dark new jew and he has
actually a couple of questions first
question is he's 16 years old his first
question is do you think it's possible
for someone at my age to start a
business and b6
well how old is he 16 years old 16 okay
yeah so actually the first thing I would
just say is there was this awesome live
stream that just happened last week on
Evans channel called is it too late for
you to be a success with the CEO of sage
Steven Kelley and it basically the whole
discussion is about you know is age
going to be a limiting factor in any way
to be successful in entrepreneurship so
in that discussion we actually talked
about how they're just was a
multi-million deal for an 11 year old
who sells lemonade to whole foods so we
were in that discussion talking about
how an 11 year old is hugely successful
so I obviously don't believe that age
has anything to do with your success in
entrepreneurship I love it for me this
is one of the things that held me back a
lot when I was first getting started I
was 19 I had a software company and I
thought that I was too young and that
people wouldn't take me seriously and
you know I didn't hire any the
background in entrepreneurship right
like parents weren't entrepreneurs I
didn't learn anything what internship at
school I don't even know why I really
wanted to be entrepreneur is aw so I had
all these limiting beliefs that people
wouldn't take me seriously I was selling
scientific software to scientists and I
wasn't a scientist and these people were
three times my age often Oh Jerry I just
got first blood look at that I all right
team is ahead and it was a big thing
like I used to always think oh I can't
I'm not gonna sell on the phone I'm just
gonna sell my email because they
couldn't really tell how old I was by
email I never used my face on any of the
you know marketing and then what what
change was I realized that you know
these guys don't really care how old I
am all they really care
as can I help them and and i realized
that i could write like our software was
good it could help them and had a lot of
valuable things that you know they
couldn't get anywhere else and and they
were willing to talk to me you know it
was it was kind of shocking and one of
the first experiences I had with that
was in my local University in Toronto
and I was just interviewing some of the
scientists and they were more than happy
to have a conversation with me because
they realized that the tool that I had
helped make would be helpful to their
business lives right and I think as long
as people see value in what you're doing
then they don't really care hold you are
it happened later to when I started
working with bigger companies one of the
first companies I worked with was
microsoft and I told this story think on
on the stream I was in there and they
asked me to come and help them with
their small business strategy and and I
thought man who am I to talk to
Microsoft right like these guys have oh
who knows how big a budget you know I'm
a nobody they know what they're doing
and then when I started talking to them
I realized oh you know what they
actually don't know much about what
they're doing and I could help them and
they saw the value and so that made a
big difference for me in terms of
getting confidence people to have to go
up and tell Microsoft hey you're doing
it wrong this is not the right way to do
it and realize that I could give them
value and so I think at some point you
know you have to have that realization
that what you do brings value and it's
not just about it's not just about age
because everybody has their limiting
beliefs right people think oh you know I
didn't go to school so I can't really
you know I can't give value I can't be
an entrepreneur you know I don't know
really what I'm doing here and at the
end of the day nobody cares nobody cares
about your schooling or your background
maybe in some some specific industries
like if you want to be a doctor then you
should go to med school but for the most
part it doesn't really make a difference
people care about is can you help them
solve a problem and when you understand
that you can then it makes all the
difference in the world so 16 years old
the question then becomes how do you
provide value like what kind of value
can you give somebody that will that
will help them can you do that you know
do you have the skills to be able to do
that and if you do then then go all-in I
think it's never been easier to be a
young entrepreneur I think there's more
and more respect for young people who
wanted to start businesses because we've
seen the success of so many other young
I think a lot of the older generation
when they look at things like social
media and they may not have any idea
what it's all about that they recognize
that they need young people on board to
help them with these things right so
really it's just about can you provide
the value if you can provide value then
you can be successful at any age at any
you know income level at any background
whatever country you're in just you be
able to provide value love it so the
second question is basically he has some
ideas I'll share with you what it is
that he was considering for his business
and he says I'm interested in so many
things from art to software to
engineering the product making I just
don't know what to do the only idea I
have been coming up with that I actually
like is making a club kind of center
with video games or purchasable food
where people can come and talk play
games listen to music and that sort of
thing but again he's kind of like is
that too ambitious all right I like it
so the idea is the idea of a what's he
waiting for yeah video games okay so he
wants video games purchasable food where
people can talk play games hang out i
think it's a it's a good idea if he's
really passionate about it i think the
main thing would be
you have a lot of interest which sounds
like he does I would just try on a small
scale different different things and see
where as you were just talking about
where is the value where is he seeing
people respond so i don't know if i'd
personally go out there and just
launched this video game hangout place
but i might try by just doing some small
test with different things and seeing
what the response is and see how how
valuable it is to people while you were
talking they tried to double team me and
I gotta kill so I'm very excited about
that I'm really sad because my stream is
actually it's like it's frozen I can't
see here your people anymore yeah L
jrice gotta kill too and I got double
team but I killed them and didn't die so
pretty training to good start to the
stream to answer that question so one
you know you don't need anybody's
permission oh crap I'm dying I'm dying
I'm dying I'm dead I'm dead okay good I
die and you'll need anybody's permission
to to tell you that you have a good idea
or not you know I look at people who
read the entrepreneur magazine top 100
best ideas to start and you could start
any of those but if you're not
passionate about it then you're not
gonna be successful with it and for me
you don't need me to say you know that
that was a good idea you should go for
it what you need to do is do something
that you're passionate cited about so
when people write in to say hey should I
start this businesses do you think it's
a good idea you think it'll be
successful it has very little to do with
the idea alone it's much more about the
passion that you have for so any any
business could be successful any idea
could work you have to have the passion
to launch it and then stick with it when
times get really tough and be creative
around it so you know that idea can work
you know the biggest metric is that your
excited about it moving on like in terms
of execution how to make it happen i
would say i would try to find a way to
start it smaller i'm a big believer in
starting small and building up it's
expensive to start a location right
think about how much is going to cost
you to start up this location get all
the you know if you need staffing
forward resources you need a physical
store you know lots of lots of money
that goes into start in that kind of
business and i would just try to find a
way to start smaller i would look at
could there be a place where I could
partner up with somebody who already has
a space and run some events around it
right start building up a community you
know could you partner up with an
internet cafe and bring something else
to the table could you partner up with a
rec center and bring something else to
the table to show one that the model
works to to start bringing in some money
for yourself and three start building up
an audience so that when you do have
your first location you're ready to rock
and roll as an example i'm a i'm the
owner of toronto dance salsa it's it's a
great place to dance and Canada's
largest salsa dance school and when the
company started I didn't start the
company but the founder when she started
it she didn't want to go out and make
them the same mistake that most people
do when they started businesses like
okay this is a retail location now but
she started out just renting from Jim's
sure ended from James and the cost at
that time I want to say 25 30 bucks an
hour three hours a night so you know
under a hundred bucks she had her costs
down she was the only one doing the
instruction so that's basically what a
cost if she can cover ninety dollars a
night then she was making money and then
that's how the company started and then
as she built it up and Google following
and built-in audience and built the base
then she was able to get her own
location and that rent is over a hundred
thousand dollars a year I know because I
pay those checks every month
money draining my bank account you know
that's a hundred thousand a year on rent
right and a lot of people would just
start up and and put that kind of
investment in may not be that much but
you know you go out and get a location
uh and you don't know if it's gonna work
or not you're gonna you know you're
going to make a ton of mistakes and so
we better to start find a way to start
smaller build it up get get some
traction get some get an audience get
some customers build a following and
then apply that to your business amazing
very cool I hope that helps dark new do
ah that's the name dark yeah i'm
wondering i'm curious where dark new jew
is from but anyway okay next next
question how's the game going good i'm
one and one i just set up my ZZ rot
portal so i'm gonna be pushing down some
towers i'm pretty excited about that
there's some people who are actually
leaving comments live on twitch that i
can't register at the tower very
exciting yeah i gotta i'll get you guys
on twitch when i die ok cuz it's Howard
to focus right now hopefully I don't die
or for very long but if I do then I'll
get to the twitch comments hey ok let's
be here next question comes from
scholastic 01 scholastic 01 is an editor
in chief at a print online magazine and
it's a fashion beauty music culture
magazine first question is how and who
would you advise to create partnerships
especially from the magazine stand point
and it looks like right now they're not
doing as well as they would had hoped so
looking to possibly create partnerships
ok i know where they still they make a
magazine yeah it's an online and print
magazine fashion beauty music culture
and so how and
who you advised to create partnerships
with specifically in the magazine
industry okay publication I just gotta
kill so excited about that okay night
okay let's let's help some magazines
what do you think all right oh yeah I
think well I love that he or she whoever
scholastic 01 is is thinking about
partnerships because I know you talked a
lot about how that's been a huge key to
your success um it's build building the
partnership so sounds like he's on he or
she's on the right track but I also I I
would want to know I guess I'm curious
from you Evan like is there a optimum
optimal time to create those
partnerships or should you do it right
in the beginning but i would i would
start by going and and basically looking
at what other people are doing and who
I'm resonating with because I'm going to
want to work you talked about this
already in this in the streams you know
partnering with people who share your
same values and so if you're going to
start looking for those partners I would
be really clear on what your values are
I mean there's so much I'm sure fashion
beauty music and culture is completely
inundated industry so really be clear on
what your values are so that when you go
look those partners you know exactly the
type of people that you would want to
partner with and I don't I don't know
you'd have to answer you know where you
go out and find those people I'm not
familiar with the magazine industry but
I suppose I'd be looking on social media
and connecting with different people
there and just kind of following and
seeing what people are doing and see
what I'm really resonating with then
reach out with them reach out to them
cool what was the name again scholastic
guerra y scholastic 01 and didn't see
what kind of partnerships right just in
general partnerships yeah no no specific
word on that just create partnerships
especially from a magazine standpoint
cool so to kind of echo what Rishi said
at the top I'm a huge believer in
partnerships I think it's the fastest
way to grow your business you know find
someone who is is strong at what your
weekend like if you're looking at a
marketing partnership you want to find
people who already have your target
audience and figure out a way that you
can work together connect with each
other and support each other it's the
fastest way to grow but it doesn't only
have to be a marketing partnership if I
think from a magazine point of view a
super common model is to partner with
collaborators like unique content right
to have a good magazine you need great
content and so that comes a lot through
partnerships I think about the you know
my website and what I've done that was
all through having 8,000 partners who
contribute to my website and I give them
exposure so it's all it's all connected
and in a super powerful way to be able
to build your business so look at the
things that you're weak at right I
really need help with this well I am not
strong at this I need content for my
magazine I need funding for my magazine
I need readership for my magazine what
are the things that you really need I
need graphic design for my magazine
right the more clear you are and what
you need the easier it's going to be to
find the right people to be able to help
you so I think a lot of entrepreneurs to
try to do things themselves too much uh
you know we may have been burned in the
past by other partners mmm and so we end
up taking everything on I'm on I just
killed the dragon pretty happy about
that I almost died doing it so my
teammate came to save me and it's so
whether you're new magazine is here
something else that the idea still holds
and that whatever you need help with
whatever your week at whatever wherever
you want to grow find people who have
already done it who have had some
success there and figure out a way you
can work out a deal to
so with the magazine again you're
looking at content I would think in
marketing is that's a one and two
strategies and often content is tied to
marketing like if you can partner with
authors who will also then give it to
their audience you know if you partnered
with 50 different people who all
contributed content for your magazine
and then they all shared it to their
audiences each one may not have a
sizable individual audience but all
these 50 people together do have a
pretty sizable audience that could be so
I'm a fan and I think you should do it
can I ask you a follow-up about that
yeah okay so can you talk a little bit
about what you do after you have been
burned in a previous partnership because
I think a lot of people might really get
hung up and that's why they do end up
doing everything themselves they just
they've already had any really bad
experience maybe with partnerships in
the past so what how do you get over
that what do you do what's the best way
to keep that what's the way to recover
it's a great question and and not just
partnerships right like you could get
burned by suppliers you can get burned
by investors you can get burned by you
know your your your spouse or boyfriend
or girlfriend like how to get back on
the saddle apt or a setback you're going
to get are lots of setbacks I think what
generally happens to a lot of people and
which is sad is that they then think
well nobody else can do it so I'm just
going to do it all myself and that's
that's a that can be really hard that
can be really hard to make something
amazing happened because to build
something of substance you can't do it
alone like you only have so many hours
in the day you need to be able to bring
people whether they're you know whether
they're on your team officially or
you're just a partner you know they care
about what you're trying to do they want
to help and they're attached to kind of
a mission that you're on
I'm super important and and again I
think too many people they try because
maybe they heard it's a great strategy
right maybe they're watching this dream
though I'm going to give that a shot and
then the first one the book work out and
then they decide that nothing is ever
going to work out and they give up on it
which is not the best thing to do g res
and i just got a kill with some some tag
team action there good job Jay rise
Junior it's a day feeling the light oh
you just have deep I'm gonna I'm gonna
slow them down for you there you go Jay
Reise um so yeah you looking at you know
how do you get back in the saddle once
you've been burned by a by a boyfriend
or girlfriend you just you realize that
I don't want to live my life alone right
like I have to get past these things to
be able to to move on not that it's an
easy thing necessarily for me I think
it's just recognizing that one that it
the first one may not work out right
along with so much pressure on it to
work and then it doesn't only they freak
out like expect it not to work at the
start obviously like you don't try but
like you look at hiring employees as an
example usually your first your first
hire doesn't work out you look at how
many companies are first hire still
around barely happens and it's not
usually on the employees usually on the
employer like it's on you you know you
don't know how to hire you don't know
what you're looking for all right I'll
so you make a lot of mistakes and you
bring on the wrong people yeah right so
you know you do your best to try to get
the right employee to start but if it
doesn't work out but you know it's it's
okay you'll find it another one you
gotta keep trying to keep going and Jay
your eyes and I have been working on a
on a project to bring on a new personal
assistant for me uh and and it's been
now this is the third trial like this
has been the hardest higher I've had to
make in a long time uh and it's one not
settling for okay right the thin people
who like yeah
they're okay but it's like it's not you
know we don't want to settle for that
and and it's hard because then you have
to go through the pain of finding the
person all over again right like here I
have someone who's good am I going to
give that up someone who's good can get
the job done but isn't great but knowing
I have to go through that insanely
painful hiring process again you know
but we're doing it because it's
important to begin if you look at if you
look at successful entrepreneurs they
always say it's about the team it's
about the team it's about the team it's
about the team so Wow build your team
amazing i'm back in watching the stream
looks like a lot of fun it's fun it's a
little stressful we're winning though
we're actually dominating I am 31 I have
three kills I've died once so that's
that's solid how's JJ how you doing four
kills no deaths so that's that's pretty
solid and our team is 17 kills seven
deaths oh so it's looking solid it's
looking like it's a good game great
that's great okay so this scholastic 01
has one more question and this is
regarding social media because he's he
or she's asking how to make more of a
social media presence so potential
investors will see that we have value
and there's a side note here I noticed
that other starter online magazines that
just started like two or two days ago
now have 10,000 plus followers it's kind
of going like what's going on why are
these people just starting and they're
getting all this crazy followers and I'm
I'm here struggling so what do you what
do you think about that Oh social media
and I make me Santa first day yeah yeah
reciate is first okay um man I'm just
going to have to say that I love social
media but this is definitely not my
area expertise but I think like anything
standing out if you if you want to stand
out for anyone whether its potential
investors your customers whoever it is
you've gotta stand up you gotta stand
out by standing up and so I think for me
that means like every single one of us
the cool advantage that every single one
of us has that no one can take away is
why are we here what do you carry that
no one else carries what is your unique
expression on the earth and that's the
cool thing is like once you tap into
that there's no competition because only
you have your fingerprint only you can
do what you do so I think that if if
this particular online magazine isn't
standing out I wonder if they're just
kind of doing what so many other fashion
beauty music culture magazines are doing
and just kind of put me you know maybe
good stuff but like what makes what
makes it amazing would be you know how
is scholastic 01 different from every
other editor-in-chief out there and I
think if he or she can tap into that
that's the beginning of being able to
stand out whether it's social media or
anywhere else I love it so one I would
say when you're looking at your
competitors not to get too caught up in
it and especially a number like
followers because it's easy to fake
followers doesn't assume that you're
super successful and to you know
tarisha's point I'd be looking at what
a statement that you want to make you
know if you want social media is not not
some massively tricky thing right you
want to share things that people want to
share that's it like is the stuff that
you're posting things that people care
about if it is they'll share it are you
posting good enough stuff are you
posting stuff that people actually want
to share like do people look at your and
whether it's you know long-form short
formal if you're sharing your your full
articles or you're just sharing you know
portables or quick snippets and
motivational bursts but you know would
you share your own stuff you know that's
always the marker for me the stuff that
I look at I want to say that I would
want to share it you know be proud to
share it myself and a lot of people are
just posting out here's the link to my
latest article you know who cares like
is it a good artist would you actually
share that yourself so if you wouldn't
then that's why nobody else is sharing
it to and that's what I'm not getting
followers either yeah there is some you
know context specific things you can do
for different platforms but right it's
still around the idea of providing value
and giving people something that they
would actually want to share with their
friends you do that you'll be successful
in socially awesome do you have a
favorite social platform you know that
Rishi know my favorite social platform I
know I know I wanted to hear one more
time beside YouTube though what do you
do you like I guess you love Twitter
right outside of YouTube yeah so I mean
the evolution for me I started uh i
started with linkedin linkedin was where
i started that was that was my home that
was where I thought I would make an
impact cuz it was supposed to be b2b and
you know hey we won lee surrendered ho
every day we surrender like what it's
over what happened I'll be surrendered
done that was though Hey yeah victory
well night let's see the quick stats
here and see the Scots boys who you got
an s minus I got what did I get come on
let's go eight plus eight plus isn't bad
it's i usually get an s something but
it's not bad she doesn't last time I
think she killed it in like a better
last time where J reyez had four kills
no deaths so i started on linkedin the
finish of the story started on linkedin
and for a while they used to tell you on
LinkedIn how well you did how how many
connections you had compared to
everybody else in your country so i was
my goal is to be like in the top 10 most
connected people in canada like you get
good you're like okay let's go crush
that let's do it um and then they
stopped showing the results so I didn't
know how much I had but at the end of
the day with linkedin I wasn't actually
getting results like I wasn't getting
business deals I wasn't finding the
value there just wasn't it wasn't worth
the time yes it might be a nice ego
boost to say hey I'm in the top 10 in
the in the country but it wasn't it
wasn't a given me any business results
so I stopped it I moved the facebook and
I like Facebook a lot and the earlier
days of facebook it then became much
more of a pay-to-play type of network so
you could still do well there but you
have to pay to get attention I'm even
you know they could track monetization
like if I knew that for every person who
came through facebook I was making a
dollar from then I could spend fifty
cents 75 cents to go out and acquire
that customer but if you have the kind
of business that you can measure it that
specifically then it's still a great
place to be it's the best place to be
for targeting but you have to be able to
make sure you're turning a profit from
it because otherwise you're just going
to throw money away so I left once it
became a pay-to-play kind of platform I
went to Twitter and i still like Twitter
what I love about twitter is how
accessible
people are you know you could tweet the
CEO of a company and get a response yeah
we're like otherwise and try try calling
up anybody and trying to get any kind of
response right like starting at the
front office or front desk and then
getting passed on to somebody else
somebody else set it up where I could
just tweet somebody and get a reply also
as you build up a following and it gives
you some clout so you know people will
reply to my tweets because of my
following um which is nice and so I like
how accessible people are on Twitter at
least in the business world compared to
other places but I moved to YouTube and
YouTube is my favorite platform because
I love video and I love I love learning
through video much more a visual person
and i just i get i love the audience i
love believe nation i love the feedback
i love being able to help out I love
consuming the content just as much as I
love making the content and so the
advisors is just to test I mean when I
when I saw Twitter I thought it was
stupid you know I like I don't want to
talk about my dog or what I ate for
lunch I get that some people want to
know that stuff it's awesome it's just
you know it's not it's not interesting
for me you know if I had to allocate the
time I spend during the day I would not
put it into talking about the food that
ain't taking pictures and putting that
up so I didn't think it was helpful and
then I did a search for my name and saw
that people were talking about me and I
wasn't have a conversation and so it's
worth testing like test different things
doesn't have to be this final end
strategy when I first went on youtube I
didn't just go all in on YouTube who was
a test I did a couple of videos and saw
how it worked I tested out of lab I
tested out periscope I tested out a
whole bunch of different things and you
understand that most of the tests don't
go anywhere but sometimes they do I
think people put too much pressure to
have all the final all in strategy
without really having tested anything so
I would jump ship a lot from different
social media platforms
I'm most active on YouTube I'm second
most active on Twitter I I have a little
bit on facebook and linkedin and the
rest but those are the two if you want
to reach me and get an Evan response
youtube and twitter the place to go what
about you we sheet last question goes to
you what's your favorite platform okay
my favorite platform youtube absolutely
yes yeah of mine I'm all in on YouTube
we had a live question from navigon on
twitch losing everything you put in and
on losing everything without financial
stability you might put yourself into
bankruptcy uh and yeah I'm not a fan of
going all in on something right one of
one of the things I keep repeating on
the streams is don't spend money to
you're making money because it happens
to low know where they spend tons of
cash on something that they think is a
great idea and then it doesn't work out
where I'd much rather invest my time
energy hustle heart whenever I launch
anything it's you know when i launched
my youtube channel i could have gone out
and bought all the gear and hire the
people to help me i had the money to do
it but I didn't do it because it goes
against my personal philosophy I always
like trying to test something out by
investing my time and if I'm starting to
see some results then I'll invest the
money that I'm making back into the
project I make it more successful oh ok
that's it alright remain Latin roots
where can people find you haha find me
on youtube a tree shook up TV what's in
your cup I most in your cup do we ask
you which in your cup today I don't
remember the answer I don't think we did
oh yes we did okay Palace that's like
what's actually in the cup but I mean
like metaphorically what's in the cup
what's in the cup today I have so much
cup of love that I get to sit at panera
right now plan LOL because message mr.
Evan couple of
I love her awesome well Richie have an
awesome day for all you guys watching
have an amazing day too great weekend
continue to believe fine and we'll see
you soon all right bye